that's a melon just started rolling down
the alleyway or the thing so that
melon's they're in the
alleyway yeah where's the alleyway motor
away no not again until dawn hey wait a
minute this isn't fair this isn't fair
this isn't
fair what's not fair I'm just trying to
insert my Bower into this tight
space okay too far sorry sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry about that you inserted it too
far Jack can't take it how did you
[__] know that only because your name
popped up and I couldn't pick you up uh
so never find me Jack no no you were
good they'll never catch my boner Jes
they'll never I can't fit my boner
through this
door it won't fit it won't fit w
oh hey Mark how's it wa wait wait wait
wait Mark will you take come
on whoa all right I'm going I'm going
hit rotation lock all of this
[Music]
raming oh no there we go oh you guys
didn't stay on that's not working we
can't it's like impossible let me Mark
can you become the can you become the
bathtub I can try oh there we go oh yes
yeah [__] yes let me let me squ Bob you
want to you want to bathe you guys
bathing in my boner juice is that what
going do boner
bath I was looking deep into your Masky
eyes let me Ram this glass see if I can
break it to the
Gman creeping me
out it ain't working [__] G man
help g man's rocking his I can tell I
can see g man's chub that's why he's
standing so far away that's what he has
in his briefcase don't be embarrassed of
your chub G man G man yeah g man Let It
Shine I was going to say Let It Shine
too let that dick
shine oh yeah let's fill mark up oh who
why did I explode a watermelon when I
grabbed it because you poked it with
your you poked my boner into it oh my
boner my boner boner that wait Mark
you're not as Hollow as the other let me
see if I can Ram a boner against the
wall and it'll or Ram a melon against
wall
I do not want to see your
webcam just just kill me just kill me
it's not worth it it's not worth it jeez
let me just Ram a boner against the wall
and see what
happens oh God I don't feel well I I I
really like this trend that's starting
the boner trend is it really is it
really new if you're really honest with
yourself are we just suddenly into
boners no I
am oh my hair is a disgusting mess
everything's a boner something boner box
boner Bill boner Bob boner cheese boner
Wade I found a boner Pony boner cheese
no I there was easy cheese on my desk it
was the first thing I looked at I'm
sorry not cheese I'm sorry want to think
of a dick cheese man all right uh waade
you got a boner Pony no why why God
[__] oh oh my God what you do whoa
that is a boner Pony what's going on
yeah you found the the place with the
boner P the boner Pony oh Jesus Christ
standing up very proud does it have a
boner things things are happening inside
of me and I don't like it oh jeez Bob
that's normal whenever you reach a
certain age sound like a hash boner
you need call in about your boner
problem oh oh gosh ohsh you're on the
boner cast what's your boner question
look look come help me please oh
God Z help me there's no helping you go
see a boner doctor throwing
uncontrollably out of me oh do you need
a do you need some boner
Mercy need some boner resist sweet boner
releas take one of those pills I don't
understand stand I'm sorry it's been
more than 4 hours this is a
mercy please oh my God this might take
oh jeesus I'll get you wait you're not
be perfect I'm
in his bow was too powerful blew off my
screen why did I have to die I just want
to come say hi to Bob's boner Bob's
boners
spinoff show
[__] I swear if that joke hasn't been
made I don't like
boners Bob's boners Bob's boners yeah
don't know why I me that
comparison and I need to love boners so
for God's sake make that
joke if I don't know if I can't love
boners I don't know what's right in the
world I don't know what I'm doing I feel
like these open doors are a misdirection
yeah both of these doors are not
supposed to be open but that's fine what
it's fine just with it someone also
opened the back doors and oh my God it
is a boner Pony boner Pony holy [__]
it's a it's a
bony the Bony most epic
bony is anybody in here with me or am I
just wasted my time oh my God this place
is [__] complicated man yeah hey
there's a a backyard upstairs going on
there's a whole bunch of stuff I was
back there but then I went away bunch of
things
ring what's
up Bob's answering hi uh I have a bit of
a problem um every time my girlfriend
sees my boner uh she laughs really hard
and then doesn't do anything with me and
also she's dating like another guy uh
what do I
do sounds like she doesn't know what a
great boner is when she season
brother that does sounds like you should
me Boner the this is terrible advice
this doesn't actually help
me hey buddy how's it going oh no what
the [__] this is a trap hello you you
sprung my trap
card hello all right goodbye I nobody
cares about your boner problem Jesus
[__] yourself I have like someone calls
in with a tiny boner problem and you're
just like [__] you man only big boners
out
here
Noy that a boner can wait who is that
who's that in the kitchen with the
melons and the things come back all
right wait open this door just slowly
open the door and stand there no the the
door yeah can't slowly open a door just
open it I suppos slly go away Mel open
it hey hi there hello welcome to the B
room are you ready
for not that door
Bob what's wrong with this oh [__]
what's what's wrong with this room you
guys don't want to be part of oh yeah
here let's let's let's just shove
everything over here hang on come on if
that door opens again why don't you want
to be part of this what's wrong blasting
that want the C your B come here chair
we got to pile the [__] up so the boner
baby can't [__] Escape
SC baby horrifying not
be that's in the opening of the boner
cast when there's the baby crying sound
that's the
boner give that baby a
boner oh my God we can have a boner baby
doesn't mean I can't have a boner it was
fun having a YouTube channel yeah I'm
pretty sure lots of this is violated
terms of service so we'll see what
happens I guess I'm not upload you don't
realize door opens from the
inside you'll never kill the boner baby
you'll never kill the boner
baby oh
[__] oh holy [__] we cannot
have thing it Canon okay wait he's just
the baby that hangs out with us while we
do boner cats why is that why is that
it's not like the baby has a boner what
yeah it's not like the baby
touches
baby I I don't know you guys so Zach was
a brown bottle and now he's gone Jack
Jack's hanging out somebody is blind as
all [__] right now who it's you way it's
you way okay I'm glad it's not me
because I was like [__] I I don't know
what happened
where you at way I'm in the courtyard
following the
bottle did did I lose him I think I lost
I think I think I lost I think he lost
him oh [__] [__]
good I've got a murder boner right now
so
hard watch the boner
Cannon oh no this end oh Bob Bob behind
you a sign that says like zero days
since last boner maybe they won't
notice zero hours since last boner uh
let me let me put in rotation locks so
they won't notice that yeah all owners
all the time full stealth waade I'm good
I think I'm
good I think
uh I think I'm good are you good okay B
power
go I'm inspecting the outside well hey
well hey hey oh wow wow oh wow jeez you
dick you were you were too bad I
couldn't let you live yeah you can't
can't rush the B not
awful oh no wait calm down calm down
it's okay okay can you move can you move
to your sort of to the to the right does
your boner point you in is that out with
my boner I couldn't move at all before
now is he in here are you fully
committing and having your dick out on
camera right now just shaking it yeah I
can do that I mean all I got to do is
pull my underwear down cuz I'm recording
in my underwear I'm boner out at least
you're wearing that for once well wait
yeah underwe is not pants that's
different yeah there's nothing worse
than like staying over there getting
ready to do a recording waking up to
that I'm the I'm the boner poner where
are you chill chill out way chill out
I'm chill I'm good chill are we in the
chill room oh look we got some sweet
boners on the Shelf look at those quity
boners those are not those some real
boners here wait let me you think I can
get in there to go see I think you
should take your boners and weight a
little I've turned it I've turned it
into a it's a it's Aang on it's a bone
or spear B bone Rod let's Sword Play Let
sword oh you guys should draw swords
yeah you guys should come sword fight
out SP hey dude we should put on our
glow-in-the dark condoms and lightsaber
Bob Bob can
you
hey
hey my boner I won now my boner sh sniff
it
out boner Jack boner up first can you
can you guys bring this let know Marx
boner is greater than can you bring this
outside where you started wait wait you
had such a good spot I'll get back my
boner my boner is making it very hard to
move if you know what I mean I can't
open bone what I mean my boner broke
hang on I swear to God if you guys don't
end up fighting
me uh you what you what wait what will
you do I will not call into boner cast
oh good B you so good is he over
here I smell I am I am near you yeah
you're really smelly smell so let me
just knock these cones over with my
boner these cones are good hey hey hey
hey my
B we've had a bonal accident wait what
are you holding a boner boner that's the
oh
[Music]
God oh my God I knew there wasn't two
cars I want Mark to go back and look at
his footage where he was right next to
me as I was stuck in the other car as
that car I was too worried about the
bone I was coming up with Boner jokes
like that's what my brain was doing he
Bon too hard man I got too deep into the
boner got boner block oh man oh that was
funny oh [__] idea there
thanks ah [__] I can't fit through doors
apparently are you a car no oh
god oh [__]
me Jesus
Christ you find him already Bob are you
okay there ET no I'm fine you going
across the moon there buddy don't look
at me I'm not sure what that oh hey hey
how's it going can you uh help me wait
wait come out to the
back oh shut up can I ride yeah yeah get
down on there that sweet boner
bike this is the saddest thing I think
I've ever seen shut up oh God Bob I'm
stuck inside of him
I can't move well I guess you'll have to
fight a good plan that sounds like a
boner cast
problem here wait wait I've got a tool
for you to use I can't pick it up though
here is it a
b no it's just does that do for me I
helped don't tell don't say I didn't
help can I do I can't I can't click on
that I'm jumping I'm crouching I'm
crouching I'm I'm try click don't [__]
it up that didn't work I didn't take any
damage wait don't fu fire okay I'm free
I got my health back oh wow Jack that's
really
good what the [__] going on over here
I'm pretty yeah that's is this you jack
good no you blew that up when you shot
Mark see it disappear I just heard Free
Falling and there was a floating box so
how does that go together I don't know
just I thought the box was supposed to
be falling but it wasn't no okay I'm I'm
going to remove all the boners off the
table so I can tell what's going on
think of a a hint that's misleading you
come up with I got a call I got to make
a call I got to make a call a hint
that's misleading I'm inside ring
ringing hey buddy you're on with the
boner cast what's your question
boner but seriously right on brother
that does it for our five o' boner uh
it's always been my dream to enter the
boner Olympics uh what can I do to train
my boner
oh you got to do some sweet Kel bro just
just hang just hang a cinder block off
Jesus hang a cinder block off your dick
and just squeeze hard man that's funny
cuz that's also a
clue that's also a clue to what prop I
he's a hanging dick block yeah you're
you're a
scrotum so hang a cinder block off my
Scot and then I'll be good enough to be
in the bone Olympics is that what you
saying yeah sweet boner pushups man
thanks
man boner click boner
away that oh you come to the Olympics
just brandishing your boner on
fire my boner is the torch and I'm just
running with my boner in hand boners on
fire you have like the boner relays as
well you just run your dick and someone
while they're running they're just
screaming at the top of their lungs cuz
it hurts so
bad
oh I that better be in your markipliers
mini
Montage the boner this has been the most
horrifying recording session I you think
this is the best problem one we've done
in a
while wait oh my god oh come Jesus I
didn't even I wasn't even paying
attention I just kind of went over here
and was like
oh I ruined Bob's spot I'm sorry my good
Bob yeah you're I feel bad now you can
do anything you want to do your spot is
giving me such I hardly control oh well
that spot's really good then yeah it's a
great spot all right it's
Bon oh
bastic I wish you could become the
horse's
bulge just the Bulge we could just run
around as horse boners oh he does have a
bulge well yeah he's got he's even got
nuts if you look really if you look down
he does who he he's got a full set of
junk down there that's a nice boner ball
that's a great set of stones
he's I don't know what's going on but
okay
okay I don't know he's made out of met
so I just need to relax he's man out of
what party like porn stars man Mak sense
cuz he's party like Boner Stars man
Boner
Stars hey now you're a boner get boner
boner that song Just devolved and now we
got
boners oh no the peekaboo the wheels on
the bus go boner boner boner boner boner
boner boner
boner it's like what did you say you
switch out the words with
poop you switch it out with
boners what
boner boner boner boner boner boner
boner boner whoever said a vlog one time
where he switched out like song
lyrics oh I can't even focus on what
we're doing Jesus I think we should play
the game where you replace a letter with
another letter but you just replace all
words with Boner I like that that's a
good boner boner boner boner no you have
discern from the the tone of voice in
the inflection what the person is trying
to say uh boner boner boner boner boner
boner boner I love sweet Vietnamese boys
oh
wait wait what is wrong with
you first
racist how in the world was that me
talking by clearly Irish accent my God
wait do you guys see me Spinning You See
Me
spinning wait
wait oh my
God Jack Jack come here Jack come here
wait can I worth it it's worth it I just
looked at the horse's
junk I can spin faster you giving him a
sweet you giving him a sweet Ana I'm
giving him a sweet
something G him a horse Rancher oh my
God that's what we call that I
don't B we can we end this Trav yeah
thank you
oh man there's a great view down here
though check that out I can just see the
thumbnail now be a something censored
going you nailed it Jack you're doing
good
Jack oh doing the Lord's work Jack I
tried to fit over here but it didn't
work oh wait wait wait
wait they don't suspect oh my
God
they never know what's going
on
wow that was Wade that I was suspected
that was Wade that was Wade of course it
was W oh we do
double what what did I
miss an O
thing
oh
um
what up up oh it's this oh that's
floating from the angle I had that thing
was
[Laughter]
not angle I had that was not Flo God
that did not sorry that did not go well
that did not go
well oh my my face hurts so much oh like
you wouldn't believe nice try oh oh it's
okay it's okay good effort oh my ass
good
effort wait please tell me you in some
way like went with the joke there or you
did that intentionally oh I hope
not oh of course I did oh good
oh thank you Wade you almost killed me
you're
welcome all right what do you see boy uh
I don't know what your Al I see you know
stuff things they're taking to habas
suisen
goding guard eising guard I don't know
why I like guard is that is it's as if
the very whips of their masters are
behind
[Music]
them you never seen
that somebody made a song no why why is
this working this is such a shitty wa is
what working huh there's something weird
going okay who are you the weird stopped
are you from the
war yes yes Grandpa I'm from the
[Music]
war
boner Going Quiet I don't like trying to
concentrate and actually play
pro try Hardy now
B
bone boner boner bone
bone old MC boner had a bone boner boner
bone bone bone bone bone
bone so Jack sings elegantly and then
Ines
boner I wouldn't have it any other
way you guys you guys need need to is
that you know are you something super
obvious yes I'm awful I'm in a horrible
spot I'm not a line very well I'm huge I
can't pay attention right now I can't
get it up in the
morning my wife oh wait wait wait guys I
thought I thought of the clue okay I've
got a lot of
wood
really I actually made a similar joke
earlier Bob to try to give them a clue
but they didn't catch
on
no
I don't know you might you might find
pornography on
me
he's what you're my computer is there a
computer room computer computers aren't
wooden oh wait these are all knocked
over uh you thatum yeah you you ran by
and you made this one swing yeah look
it's doing it again the bookshelf just
swings up here the infinite wobble
bookshelf oh oh I I don't know why oh
old Magazine
porn okay yeah digital porn
okay shut up don't laugh at me everyone
over 30 is just shaking their head right
now first of the episod old magazine for
no God I fcking knew you were one of
those old magazine I said I wasn't one
of those you said I knocked them over
yeah you knocked them over didn't knock
him over getting up there you [__]
knocked him over I was the fourth
bookshelf and they all were perfectly in
awn was like moving the entire time [__]
wait wait are you here too [__] nuggets
can I have my pornography when you're
done with it oh magazine pornography
magazine pornography shut up you know
what I meant that's going to be the
title of the episode oh magazine C
magazine pornography oh it's a thing
well not Playboy doesn't do it anymore
they don't have magazine pornography is
a thing it's all about the Articles it
is apparently yeah D yeah I submitted my
entry to Penthouse Forum like six times
I'm pretty sure next time's the winner
don't worry all right cool your joke
gonna be in it I'll keep an eye out I'll
get a subscription to one of those
magazine pornographies just for that
reason I've already
got I mean the fact there were three and
two were knocked over kind of gave that
away oh you think that but you guys just
ran past like me yeah I'm I'm doing some
hard drugs Mark can you see what I mean
I see what you mean you kind of oh I do
see what you
mean iiz drug Jack it's not worth it you
have a life to live you can still be
good I'm just injected myself with
[Music]
sweet
what
why did your brain go to
sperm come over here and sit in my
lap oh god well
what